happy monday reject nation how is the
beginning of your week going i heard
yesterday that
marvel might be releasing some type of
trailer today and then uh as soon as it
came up got a lot of people on social
media being like
gotta cover this you gotta check it out
there's some special footage in here
so let's just swing into action shall we
how are you i'm so good
the rest is great
i love being with people it's the most
incredible thing in the world
[Music]
we're all part of one big family
[Music]
so nice to hear stanley's
[Music]
we're all voice of one universe
[Applause]
[Music]
cool oh i could binge all these
officials
i love these
oh man
[Applause]
that doesn't make you want to go back to
the theaters yeah right
[Applause]
oh no
oh
[Music]
nice
little little new bits here
[Music]
[Applause]
shanxi
[Music]
in there sexy kumail
[Music]
of course no footage from spider-man
or loving thunder
wakanda forever
the marvels ooh that's through the
captain marvel two title okay
it's such an exciting trailer
[Music]
that was in the other show though right
that last punch yeah i don't recall that
being there no
no it's from the same scene but no i
don't think we saw that i don't recall
that look being there
we got to break down each punch oh i
love this yeah
i absolutely love this i believe this is
like reminding you
as an audience remember the joy that
going to the cinemas of sharing marvel
has brought you by being in the theaters
especially with going with that audience
reaction moving from
it's like you just can't get that from a
streaming service you just can't get
that at home
like you're not gonna get that same
feeling some monumental moment like that
in an
mcu flip oh absolutely not no and i mean
i love that interlude of this because
i even kind of forgot that we were
watching a trailer for a little bit just
this prolonged
moment and i think it's it's fascinating
that they they even probably knew
they're like we got to set up a camera
in the theater for this
if we bootleg anything on a legit level
it has to be this because this is gonna
be an iconic memorable moment and yeah
just to even revisit that was really
wonderful
you have this like voice of stan lee you
have this footage of chadwick boseman
it's like
rest in peace to both of those legends
right there hearing stan lee's words and
just reminding you of like the beauty
that well
just it's like what 13 years ago when
the mcu's first sprung up into existence
and
how far we've come it's a glorious
legacy but of course
the last half of the trade you got new
footage
you get some new little images of black
widow here
some slight new footage of shang qi
already we already got a new trailer
just
very recent but then what do we got here
at eternals
um okay let's go slowly that is some
hayek as ajax
looks like she's living on her secluded
farm life here
the power shot you got here okay on the
right that's gilgamesh
athena angela jolie icarus gemma chan as
cersei that's gotta be sprite and uh
kingo it looks like there's a whole
bunch of people behind them over here
um as well i believe this movie they're
all like kind of separated but then they
start coming back
together and of course you know uh you
know i know all the character names
that's what the directors say who just
won the oscar chloe's
shout out all these other random names i
can't remember the director's name
this looks just like no mad land i can
definitely see i mean this shot right
here
kind of like yeah that looks like a
chloe's house i mean it's a beautiful
shot and then
on the left here you see druid on the
right that's fastos who's gonna be
played by brian tyree henry
who actually will be marvel's first gay
superhero which is pretty cool and then
you got angela jolie
doing an angelina jolie moment you know
with her sword gonna be a deadly ass
warrior but
from everything i'm hearing it seems
like cersei will be the scene stealer of
this i love how our first look of
eternals
is so simplified you know oh yeah just a
few very striking images to get you
going and to set the tone the mood etc
and then you got no in this shot over
here you got makari
speeding into frame they're all in their
hero outfits but i love how it's still
so far away so you can't
get the clearer shot of their hero
outfits someone in the comments tell us
where this is all right i don't know
where that is and you got like cersei
saying we're the ones who changed
everything because we're gonna have to
uncover a lot the eternals have been
around
during the entire time of the reign of
thanos
you know so there's a lot to uncover
here in the different evolutions of
you know offshooting humanity and
whatnot this is one shot of camille as
kingo so the comics
kingo is japanese he's actually like a
an
action star in the comics and then here
they changed his ethnicity obviously
because camille nanjiani
is not japanese and he's going to be a
bollywood star here and you could just
feel that
that sense of like a little smart ass
presence that he's got here yeah he does
have that kind of
smolder than a polygonal star might
bring to something you even get a sense
of like a
a strange kind of tone even just from
those little images because the eternals
are these like crazy ass
beings oh yeah you know and you're gonna
have the deviance in there as well
yet it feels like so grounded yeah
new and yet in this imagery like they've
always been here and like they
are ancient even though it is just a
couple images like they're doing really
nicely to showcase that like i don't
know
there's something in the way that
they're framing and lighting this stuff
that does
feel very elemental and very much yeah
like these people have just been always
somewhere in this universe watching over
even if now is finally the time they'll
reveal themselves on this
timeline you know and even though
they're like these great beings who are
they're eternal
even though they've been around for so
long the environments that were
showcasing them in here
are so simplified yeah you know there's
not like this big i'm sure the trailer
will show us a little more of that oh
there we go okay the title reveals the
marvel's because you got
miss marvel who's also going to be in
here along with captain marvel and
monica rambo will be in there too and
then they got the official title for
black panther two wakanda forever this
is as soon as it seems perfect
that is a perfect title oh yeah that
seems like the natural follow-up i mean
they've had some of the actors coming
out recently speaking about how what
ryan coogler has done with the script
will really honor
uh the legacy of chadwick boseman within
that film
and i expect nothing less at this point
absolutely then of course you got some
slight new shots of uh black widow as
well which comes out very soon from now
can't wait to check it out i love this
this is a
fun way to start off the month of may
right here absolutely guys what did you
think of this
are you excited for the eternals can't
wait for the official trailer uh
it's going to be an exciting ass weird
movie anyway guys
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least
anissa oliva anissa it was your birthday
just a few days ago
but you know what for as long as we are
around
we will eternally love you you have done
so many amazing things for us you have
been unbelievably supportive in every
which
way i love you to death and i wish we
properly shouted you out in a youtube
video on your actual birthday but hey
a marvel trailer is bigger than any
other
video that came out on the 30th of april
that we could have shouted you out in
marvel trailers
birthday the marvel trailers are
returned they are yeah they are
this trailer's about legacy anissa you
are part of the real rejects
legacy you're something special i adore
you with all my heart you're our stan
lee
one day john will smack you in the
bottom
respectfully
you